you should be drowned dude in in public
everyone should make fun of you no if
you get a DUI on one of those
hoverboards you should be sentenced to
death
[Music]
all right everybody especially Nick this
is a this is a sad one oh no why
especially me dude because I just don't
want you to get your expectations you're
the most sensitive one okay yeah I have
the most sensible one in the room
already smiling and I said it was sad
dude I look at this guy and I just can't
help butts a smile you know hey you're
very sweet so try to smile the whole
video recently
there was this newlywed couple Eric and
Samantha Hutchinson the day they get
married like on their wedding day get it
get say it faster
you're building too much on their
wedding day their names are Eric and
Samantha Hutchinson newlyweds on their
wedding day you said that like three
times right in South Carolina
all right
um they get into a golf cart you know
because you know sometimes I told you
golfing sucks I told you mid times
they go to their gym and then their
Gym's on fire everybody's stealing
impossible
plates are not flammable
so they
family members and then this 25 year old
named Jamie komarowski uh is hitting 65
drunk as [__] in this like 25 mile an
hour spot 65 on a golf cart you could do
65 no no he was in a car the the drum
driver was in a car I'm like damn dude
Anthony was kind of like smiling bro
where you're saying that what are you
talking about now you're not it's the
punch Line's on its way yeah I know [__]
dude so is that barbell Brigade right
that's not no it's not oh whoa
increasingly flammable weights are a
huge difference they don't even make
those dude
[Laughter]
they're plows
into
just immediate like day of your the duty
of the husband he has to exact Vengeance
and kill for the driver he has to that
that would be the Poetic Justice how
would you do it you were just before we
started rolling you were talking about
how you want to like drown Tiff like how
would you I drowned that guy dude
Justice in the situation to play Devil's
Advocate
it is better on day one than to build a
life together and then it's easier to
start over now that's a good idea all
right right that's the Silver Lining
it's a little bit easier to
to start all over when when it just
started yeah
yeah what do you think Walter I I
just to add on to a mixing I don't I
don't know that drowning is enough yeah
like you know you know like when you
when you watch TV shows and movies and
the exact revenge and they shoot them
yeah I don't think that's enough it's
not satisfying it doesn't feel good you
gotta you have to do you have to be able
to you should learn like how to
resuscitate someone I told you Korean
people are the best so then when you
when you like you tie them up and you
torture them a little bit and they and
they're about to die you have to know
how to resuscitate them so you can
continue on oh you know what be a good
one you have an aquarium a custom
aquarium built that you could stick your
upper half in so they're drowning and
then the bottom half you soak them in
gasoline and set them on fire so even
when they're dying they're confused
they're like am I like in water or
burning It's the Best of Both Worlds die
from shock yeah so and then you add some
pop quiz questions and see if they can
answer them fast yeah
and then when they when they pass out
from the pain you you empty you douse
the uh then you flip it you put the
water on the legs and then
[Laughter]
Icy Hot commercial yeah exactly
Shaquille O'Neal endorsed it yeah yeah
do you think that because of the context
of the situation like the story what had
happened where it happened wedding day
all that stuff it should add to the
punishment because like you know
somebody might just die of like
involuntary homicide via drunk driving
on a regular day but it's not their
wedding day if it's on their wedding day
do you feel like you need like to exact
more Justice it's not supposed to
but it will in my opinion like it's not
supposed to like it's just like you're
not like family members or friends of
the deceased don't get a say in what the
punishment is and they're not they're
not supposed to but
you know I mean well one that's what
sways the jury ultimately but that's
extra painful though in it like on the
day that you remember because it's
supposed to be yeah I think it super
helps for civil cases those are the
happiest days of my life because it's
the first time they're having sex yeah
of course I mean hopefully this dude who
hit the cart has money because if not
then right
so the drunk guy drove onto the grounds
no um they drove onto the flammable
weights at the gym
it doesn't make sense I heard there's
one that's on to the weights I feel like
there's like there's a truck on a squat
rack is that what you're saying it
doesn't even make sense it's been words
into my mouth right now okay but I think
I think workout benches are flammable
because there's foam inside dude barbell
is so flammable they're not at Dakota
Horrible's a fire hazard huge fire it's
like fire extinguishers like people are
lifting weights with gasoline don't
taste me a gasoline Gap
we have like 45 fire extinguishers in
there all expired
do you shake them once like once a week
they're supposed to shake them the
protocol to shake them every five
minutes because Anthony's gonna [__]
tell us shake them every five minutes do
you have handheld ones you guys should
yeah
the shake weight that's the best so were
they on the golf course no you're the
one who said that then where the [__]
where did this truck come from but it's
not a golf course is it all that matters
is that they were in a golf cart so they
were driving on the street there's
things like golf carts at Coachella that
so it might just be on like a wedding
venue just like a venue what did the
drunk dude gardeners have like golf
carts on wedding venues you know what I
mean is it like Happy Gilmore where the
dude drove onto the thing knocked the
tower down kind of thing or did the golf
cart go or shouldn't have like on the
road or some [__] uh I'm pretty sure
regardless it's the guy who was uh three
times over the legal driving limit and
drunk that like in the toxicology report
like regardless of where they were it's
his fault yeah but still though it's
like it is interesting because sometimes
you do see like golf carts on the like
the streets and you're like hey some of
those the ones the ones that are on the
street they have to have license plates
and registry they do they do yeah but
also though what are you doing yeah why
are you on the road why are you on the
asphalt dude stuff is super relaxed now
in L.A like have you seen the guys on
the dirt bike yeah the dirt bike gangs
are like straight out of Rumble and
Bronx dude those guys are a little
[__] bro but is it like the gangs
that can't be stopped because the
individual
no they won't they won't Chase small
Vehicles period
so if you're like on a motorcycle it's a
do not Chase yeah it's more damaged if
something happens during the pursuit
yeah and their bikes are faster yeah but
even like nowadays you see so many no
plates just chilling there's so many
cars nothing on it yeah they don't get
pulled over at all or like the
individual drivers in the carpool lane
I would think that they would want to
pull them over because discussed the
increase of revenue for the state is
tremendous because it's like a thousand
dollar or fifteen hundred dollars what
that is fifteen hundred bucks that's a
lot like 350. what's 350.
did you change so quick I gotta tell you
I gotta tell you 1500 sounds better but
fine 350. uh it's like 350. but like I
count like in five minutes like 10 cars
there's a lot of golf carts in downtown
though a lot yeah yeah a lot of people
have them and they'll just like is it
just because it's easier to like yeah
even even at the brewery people ride
golf carts to go like around the area
like get groceries but you know they can
get a DUI though that's the thing as
long as if it's a moving thing you can
get do you want a bicycle you're on a
bicycle you can get on a scooter that's
so embarrassing bro you get a DUI on a
bike so embarrassing you should be
drowned dude in public everyone should
make fun of you no if you get a DUI on
one of those hoverboards you should be
sentenced to death so because you know
because I have an electric scooter I
asked my friend I go hey if I take this
to the bar and then like drink and then
go home can I get DUI she goes yes
because there's a motor inside so you'll
get it but your chances of killing
someone is way lower no but self-harm
though is what what the laws allegedly I
see oh yeah but that cops also also like
you got to be [__] screwing like an
idiot from the cop to be like let me
pull this one I saw you swerving because
sober people be eating [__] on those
scooters from time to time oh did you
say the bride and the groom died no just
the bride oh that's fine oh God I'm just
kidding that's [__] up oh my God
that's fine so what's gonna happen to
the guy she did say though what happened
with golf I hope this day lasts forever
she did say did the groom get hurt too
I think that there are injury is
definitely one other family member that
sucks man for real injuries but the
green was like technically okay you hate
to hear about DUIs and how they just
kill random folks bro because it happens
so much happens a lot dude or you know
you know what's the funniest when you
see dudes on the news that have like
multiple like 90 wise and [__] you're
like how the [__] yeah what are we doing
about those guys but in Nevada you can
get your DUI dropped to like a different
like a ticket that's why he went oh you
get it the charge while he loves Vegas
like like when you so when you go to
Vegas you'll see these Billboards and
like it'll be like blah blah DUI call us
and um what that's for is it's not like
California where they're just calling
the defend you like you want them to
defend you in Nevada they can get it
dropped down to like a ticket
wow I didn't know that
[Music]